The pressure on address space usage spurred the
adoption of classless interdomain routing or CIDR which
was adopted in 1994. The idea is that
instead of having fixed network ID and host
ID portions of the 32 bits. Instead, we
would simply have an IP address, and what
is known as a mask. Where the mask
is variable length, and indicates the length of the
network ID. So, for example, suppose we have
an IP address like 65.14.248.0/22. Well in this
case our 32 bits look like so, but this doesn't tell us how long the network id
and how long the host ID should be.
The /22 indicates the mask length, which says
that the first 22 bits should represent the
network ID. Now the key is that this mask
can be variable length. And the mask length
no longer depends on the range of IP addresses
that are being used. This allows those allocating IP
address ranges, to both allocate a range that's more
fitting to the size of the network. And also
not have to be constrained about how big the
network ID should be depending on where in the
IP address space the prefix is being allocated from.
Of course now the complication is that it's possible to have overlapping address
prefixes. For example, 65.14.248.0/24
overlaps with 65.14.248.0/22. The red prefix is actually
a subset of the black one. So supposing these two entries both show
up in an Internet routing table, what are supposed to do? The solution
is actually to forward on what's called the
longest prefix match, meaning that if a routing
table has two overlapping entries that it should
forward according to the entry that has the
longest prefix, or the longest mask length. Intuitively
that makes sense. Because the prefix with the
longer mask length is more specific than the
prefix with the shorter mask, or the larger prefix.